he has pitched very well at home
he has a terrific record pitching in
this ballpark and it's a good ballpark
for him it's big this would be his 16th
career start at the big a six and one
with a 216 earned run average he's got a
great fastball a great
splitter
very good slider he'll throw a cutter
from time to time and a curveball he
will throw over but the blue jays are
the best fastball hitting team in
baseball they need to look for the
fastball early jump on it and when you
get it don't miss it
and there's a nasty splitter that he got
springer to wave at he missed it badly
struck him out it's a good one right
down looks like a strike ends up out of
the strike zone expanding his own got
ahead of the count 02 and finished off a
hitter this had success against him
hit hard diving catch
gosling
you know the goose has got to be loose
at third able to control that baseball
in the glove ball couldn't have been hit
any harder by simeon that's a loud out
right there and two are gone so now in
all likelihood a matchup between the two
players who are currently the top two
mvp candidates in the american league
shohei ohtani and vladimir guerrero jr
first pitch swinging and a ground ball
sneaks under the glove of gosselin into
left field that'll be a base hit for
guerrero so full count we'll see what
gives here and the next pitch and this
is popped in the air not very deep at
all left center field coming in is upton
he'll make the call and catch and that
is how the inning will end just three
starts ago he faced this angel ball club
for his career this is his sixth career
start he has not fared well in this
ballpark has earned running average in
three previous starts here in anaheim is
551 but this year he's pitched very well
against them in two previous starts he's
allowed just six hits in 12 total
innings oh johnny hit a double off
barrios earlier this year homered off
him in 2019. here's the next pitch and
that ball's clobbered into left center
field it's a line drive out by the wall
it's going to bang off the wall shohei
will stop at second and he leads things
off in the bottom of the
first inning with a ringing double
that's his 25th double of the season
epos really hit hard
this is fun already here's david
fletcher 305 average coming in swings at
the first pitch and pops this one up on
the first base side in shallow right the
ball is going to be dropped by the first
baseman vlad guerrero ohtani can only go
from second to third he thought that
ball might be caught lady junior tried
to make an over the shoulder catching
very shallow right he just cleared the
infield dirt and had the ball pop off
his glove couldn't make the catch
1-2 and upton has popped it up guerrero
is there infield fly rule in effect
two down the bases remain loaded as
barrios tries to battle his way out of
this
this one is popped up and how about this
makes the catch in front of valera
and barrios pitches out of a bases
loaded jam and the angels fail to score
the last two batters
loaded itani 3-1
right field
adele
got it got a good read on that one adele
ranging to his right in right center
makes the catch to end the inning
marsh to left field dickerson back got
turned around and it's off the
[Applause]
one thing that dickerson realized this
ball was hit well right off the bat he
turned immediately and started running
for the fence now suzuki infields back
an out can produce a run
out to center hitchhike on the run adele
tags there's the catch coming home
strong throw and he's fired
and adele will score
gillidell has good speed able to tag on
that one pretty good job by grichik he
made it close there at the plate this is
very unburrios-like he's only had two
starts all year out of 22 where he's
walked more than three and he's walked
four here already bags are loaded here's
the 1-1 that's a ball bounced by the
mount and threw into center field one
run will score another is going to come
home and also going first to third on
that one will be
fletcher
that's a two-run single for walsh it's
three-nothing angels this time he gets a
fastball puts a really good swing on it
hits it hard right back up the middle
and still a chance to get some more we
just won out runners at first and third
gosling the hitter
into right field gosling finds a hit
another run
fletcher scores walsh moves up the
second
four nothing angels really good at bat
by phil gawson this is a good pitch a
curveball down and off that outside part
of the plate phil gaza just stays right
on it the batter is justin upton 1-1
bounce back to the mound stopped by
burrills goes the second for one relay
to first that's going to be an inning
ending double play
iglesias moves up to second base and now
kurt suzuki will be the batter with two
away
that is a fair ball into the corner it
goes
iglesias round third
and he'll score and suzuki makes it five
nothing second rbi
of the night for kurt suzuki sac fly
first at bat rbi double
second in there
simian at second nobody out
and he got him looked like a good slider
on the outside corner and guerrero
strikes out so that's the first down to
the inning and now tayaska hernandez
and that's a basin into left field
simeon had to wait to make sure was
going to get through still will come
around to score easily an rbi single
forte oscar hernandez gets the blue jays
on the board tony's pitch count is you
know somewhat high this is the fourth
inning and he's at 65 pitches line drive
right center field this is going to be
rbi number 70. hernandez in to score
easily gretchen gliding into second it
is five to two thornton inherits a
runner at second with one out of the
bottom of the fifth the blue jays down
by three adele has walked and struck out
here's his 2-2 it's a bouncer by the
mountain hits the second base bag and
shoots out into center field and coming
in and scoring from second will be
iglesias boy joe adele couldn't have
placed that one any better right there
rbi single for adele makes it six to two
angels here it comes
breaking ball
swim on and missed and that's chased and
missed a slider gets guriel that might
be the last pitch that ohtani will throw
tonight wessel iglesias got the last out
of the eighth trying to get three outs
in the ninth trying to seal this win for
shohei ohtani
and lourdes looks like he got it and he
did guriel sends one just inside the
foul pole down the left field line
number 14 on the season it is 6-3
dropped
picked up
ball game angels winning mcclasey saves
it finishes here how good was otani
tonight